en italie le green pass c'est moins de
pression pour les restaurateurs et les
clients dans ce restaurant français de
rome le contrôle des bases sanitaires se
fait avant tout avec le sourire
donc nous la façon de contrôler les
passes annie terre c'est toujours avec
souplesse si on reste des restaurateurs
donc on commence par accueillir le
client on leur donne le menu on leur a
bien précisé qu'on leur demanderai quand
il serait disponible de nous présenter
l'organe passe et c'est ce que j'ai fait
est acceptable ou en fait une fois
qu'ils se sont assis qu'ils ont reconnu
leurs serveurs qui sont restés dans
l'environnement qu'ils apprécient sans
aucune difficulté je leur demande et
nous présenter une passe
lobée les professeurs
pour s'attabler en terrasse pas besoin
d'être vaccinés
gildas mahé fondateur du restaurant le
carré français estiment que la souplesse
de l'état italien à sauver le monde de
la restauration je pense que le fait que
l'état italien eni comme critère d'avoir
une seule dose pour obtenir son gré une
passe de pouvoir déjeuner l'extérieur
tout ça a laissé une opportunité de
survie ou de quasi normalité au monde de
la restauration en italie et j'ai
beaucoup de mal pour mes collègues
français quand je vois comme il sont
traités parce qu'on ne leur laisse pas
cette chance cette chance d'une choix de
la souplesse et nous nous avons résisté
grâce à cette façon et à ses critères
très particulier l'italie dès le début
de la crise le chef d'entreprise et son
équipe ont dû se réinventer et penser à
différents concepts pour continuer à
faire tourner la boulangerie la
pâtisserie et le restaurant à plein
temps à chaque problème on a créé d
une façon de contourner le problème par
des solutions opérationnelles
on est restés ouverts on est boulanger
donc on et commerces de première
nécessité autour de la boulangerie son
nez d'autres services qui se rapprochait
de la cuisine nos équipiers sont devenus
des chauffeurs livreurs les boulangers
ont été au boulot sans jamais s'arrêter
on est extrêmement pédagogue auprès des
clients on a créé des services nouveaux
de livraisons et donc à la fin si on
fait la combinaison de tout ce qui nous
est tombé dessus on a réussi à s'en
sortir un peu de france en italie pour
le plus grand bonheur de ses clients qui
jouent le jeu oui je me semble plutôt
rassuré
mais en même temps disons que j'essaye
toujours une place assez isolé sauf si
je suis avec quelqu'un de la famille
bien évidemment si je suis seul voilà
j'essaie d'appliquer quelques petites
règles
même très simple voilà la distance par
exemple
je pense que c'est une bonne chose parce
que vous pouvez aller là où vous voulez
et je crois qu être vaccinés est une
chose vraiment importante car nous
pouvons recommencer à vivre et à
pratiquer des activités
à ce jour 62 % des italiens âgés de plus
de 18 ans sont vaccinés le gouvernement
italien a annoncé un tour de vis en vue
de la rentrée scolaire dès le 1er
septembre prochain les professeurs et
les étudiants auront l'obligation d'être
vaccinés